Jake:这一个
Jake: This one.
Jake:一个插头是吧
Jake: Just one plug, right?
Shure: 是的然后咱们弄几个锅
Shure: Yeah, and then we'll use a few pots.
Shure: 是弄一个锅还是两个锅
Shure: Should we use one pot or two pots?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Shure: 一个锅
Shure: One pot.
Jake:有两个锅是吧
Jake: There are two pots, right?
Shure: 对有两
Shure: Yeah, there are two.
Jake:这个不用垫
Jake: This one doesn't need power.
Lucia: 他们居然真的有运动过这个房子
Lucia: They actually did work out in this house.
Shure: 个锅那就用一个这个吧先
Shure: Then let's use this one first.
Shure: 用两个锅
Shure: Use two pots.
Jake:一个不用电
Jake: One doesn't need power.
Jake:就一个用电
Jake: Just one needs power.
Shure: 底下还有一个不用电的
Shure: There's another one downstairs that doesn't need power.
Jake:咱没那么多差异
Jake: We don't have that many differences.
Alice:这个太短了这里
Shure: 这气好像不是那么多问题
Shure: This gas doesn't seem to be a big issue.
Shure: 应该也不大
Shure: It shouldn't be a big deal.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
Lucia: 冰箱的电源吗
Lucia: Is this the fridge power?
Jake:可以用对
Jake:但是插墙上就行
Shure: 我操
Lucia: 你在这边
Lucia: 我拿上来了
Jake:看一看还有看还有多少
Alice:这个叉子
Alice:上面插排插插排插排插插排
Shure: 对这个插座上面
Alice:会不会有安全隐患
Shure: 没有没有
Lucia: 不会不会
Shure: 死不了放心真的
Alice:真的吗
Jake:这个大家都是这么火的
Shure: 对
Shure: 都已经如此生活30年了
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 没事这个不会的啦这个没问题的
Shure: 没问题
Jake:外边都是这么搞
Jake:并且我们这个是民牌插足
Jake: And ours is a popular brand.
Alice:公牛是吗
Alice: Bull, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:好看到公牛我放心了
Alice: Great, seeing the bull logo makes me feel relieved.
Shure: 然后就是坐这的同学稍微注意一些
Shure: So, everyone sitting here, just be a bit careful.
Tasha: 哈哈由我来进行一个开箱仪式吗
Tasha: Haha, should I do the unboxing ceremony?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Tasha: 好好
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Lucia: 开箱的工作交给你了
Lucia: The unboxing job is yours.
Shure: 这白菜洗没洗呢
Shure: Has this cabbage been washed?
Lucia: 我负责取快递你负责开箱
Lucia: I handle picking up the package, you handle unboxing.
Alice:还没呢
Alice: Not yet.
Shure: 那要不洗洗一下子
Shure: How about we give it a quick wash?
Alice:确实得洗
Alice: Yeah, it needs to be washed.
Alice:金针菇啥的也得洗一下
Alice: The enoki mushrooms and stuff need to be washed too.
Alice:这种也得过一下
Alice: This stuff needs a rinse as well.
Alice:干嘛
Tasha: 吃吗
Alice:哦
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Tasha: 啊哈
Tasha: Aha.
Alice:谢谢
Alice:没洗手
Alice: Didn't wash your hands.
Tasha: 不干不净吃了没病
Alice:好
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 谢谢
Shure: Thanks
Shure: 虽然没洗手
Shure: Even though I didn't wash my hands
Shure: 但是不干不净
Shure: But you know, a little dirt never hurt
Shure: 吃了没病
Shure: Eating it won't make you sick
Tasha: 他问了
Tasha: He asked
Jake:我怎么知道我订单尾号是什么
Jake: How would I know what the last digits of my order are?
Tasha: 感觉像诈骗
Tasha: Feels like a scam
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:不是不是订单尾号快递
Jake: No, no, it's not the order number, it's the delivery
Tasha: 什么时候吃晚饭
Tasha: When do we eat dinner?
Lucia: 快
Lucia: Soon
Shure: 打算在群里喊一下
Shure: Planning to announce it in the group
Shure: 回家吃饭了
Shure: Time to go home for dinner
Jake:没吧没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no, not at all
Alice:可以再来一个吗
Alice: Can I have another one?
Tasha: 你吃啊
Tasha: You eat it
Alice:他们是不够了
Tasha: 没事不是每个人都要吃到一个
Tasha: It's okay, not everyone needs to have one
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:那我再来一个吧
Alice:那个长的最好看
Tasha: 啊这个能至于
Tasha: Ah, this is really necessary
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice:我也觉得
Alice: I think so too
Alice:因为他没有被压
Alice: Because it wasn't pressed
Shure: 啊稍微稍微冲一下
Shure: Ah, just rinse it a bit
Shure: 虽然这应该是干净的
Shure: Even though it should be clean
Tasha: 其实我想问这个
Tasha: Actually, I wanted to ask this
Alice:嗯你说什么
Alice: Uh, what did you say?
Tasha: 那个瓦斯罐应该装在哪
Tasha: Where should the gas canister be placed?
Shure: 装完了装进去了
Shure: It's already in
Tasha: 装进去吧
Tasha: Put it in, right?
Tasha: 嗯行
Tasha: Okay, got it
Shure: 我宿舍就有
Shure: I have one in my dorm
Shure: 一个非非常不安全
Shure: It's very, very unsafe
Alice:真牛逼
Alice: That's badass
Tasha: 我没有
Tasha: I don't have one
Shure: 大家不要学
Shure: Don't try this at home, folks
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly
Shure: 也可以烧水的哦
Shure: You can also use it to boil water
Shure: 电水热水壶
Shure: With an electric kettle
Tasha: 月饼
Tasha: Mooncake.
Shure: 还在楼下
Shure: Still downstairs.
Tasha: 他们还有3个人是吧
Tasha: There are still three of them, right?
Alice:我们学校前一段还着火了
Alice: Our school caught fire a while ago.
Tasha: 那好吧
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why?
Jake:用擦板吃火锅
Jake: Using a blackboard eraser to eat hotpot.
Alice:嗯有人吸烟
Alice: Yeah, someone was smoking.
Alice:哦这好像不让说的
Alice: Oh, we're not supposed to say that.
Alice:无所谓哈哈
Alice: It doesn't matter, haha.
Alice:没关系啊
Alice: It's okay.
Lucia: 关系没事他会把这段删掉的哈
Lucia: No worries, he'll edit this part out, haha.
Jake:跪下不让说
Jake: Kneel down, don't say that.
Alice:不删也行无所谓
Alice: It's fine if he doesn't, it doesn't matter.
Shure: 有人逼逼哈哈哈
Shure: Someone is babbling, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 第一
Tasha: First.
Lucia: 那我给你手动做音效
Lucia: I'll make the sound effects for you manually.
Shure: 然后他在逼逼的时候他逼逼的哈哈
Shure: And when he's babbling, he just babbles, haha.
Lucia: 你现在说吧
Lucia: You can talk now.
Lucia: 哈哈哈咪哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha, meow haha.
Alice:哈哈咦
Alice: Haha, yuck.
Alice:无所谓这个
Alice: It's okay.
Lucia: 我们学校之前也有过但好像是电动车
Lucia: Our school had one too, but it was an electric scooter.
Alice:然后那个救护车开到楼下了
Alice: Then an ambulance arrived downstairs.
Alice:我还在睡觉
Alice: I was still asleep.
Alice:完全没有听到
Alice: I didn't hear anything.
Alice:他们在群里一直在吵我们要不要跑
Alice: They were arguing in the group whether to run or not.
Alice:要不要跑哈
Alice: Should we run or not, haha.
Alice:没有听到声音
Alice: I didn't hear anything.
Lucia: 所以 大家精神状态都很稳定吗
Lucia: So, was everyone's mental state stable?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:小的不用跑
Alice: Small ones don't need to run.
Alice:大的跑不了
Alice: Big ones can't run.
Alice:洗菜
Alice: Washing vegetables.
Jake:鼓手是
Jake: The drummer is...
Jake:就是是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:哈哈啊
Jake: Haha
Shure: 可以可以
Shure: Okay, okay.
Jake:打击乐手
Jake: Percussionist.
Alice:这点有餐盘啥的吗
Alice: Do we have any trays here?
Alice:还是楼下有
Alice: Or are they downstairs?
Tasha: 这好像也有
Tasha: I think we have some here too.
Alice:洗一下吧
Alice: Let's wash them.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: There's none.
Alice:这个不用洗
Alice: This one doesn't need washing.
Lucia: sorry不是这个
Lucia: Sorry, not this one.
Alice:这个这个不用
Alice: This one, this one doesn't need washing.
Tasha: 别的都不用好像
Tasha: Seems like the others don't need washing either.
Alice:这个需要吗
Alice: Do we need this?
Alice:不用吧这个要
Alice:嗯拿碟装吧
Alice: Hmm, let's put it on a plate.
Lucia: 嗯碟的话不够
Lucia: Hmm, that's not enough if we order.
Lucia: 咱有8个人
Lucia: We have eight people.
Alice:不不不是，这个
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:魔芋是不是得下楼切
Alice: Should we cut the konjac downstairs?
Alice:这儿有有没有大一点
Alice: Is there a bigger one here?
Lucia: 有没有小工具
Lucia: Any small tools?
Alice:我想要那个
Alice: I want that one.
Alice:我洗白菜啊
Alice: I'll wash the cabbage.
Lucia: 啊你说你说碗吗
Lucia: Ah, are you talking about bowls?
Alice:大碗对
Alice: Yes, big bowls.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one?
Alice:我洗白菜
Alice: I'll wash the cabbage.
Lucia: 这个碗我前两天洗过
Lucia: I washed this bowl a few days ago.
Lucia: 我涮一下就可以
Lucia: I'll just rinse it.
Lucia: 对但其他的
Lucia: Yes, but the others...
Lucia: 这上面的碗应该还没怎么用过
Lucia: These bowls on top haven't been used much.
Lucia: 我先都拿出来
Lucia: I'll take them all out first.
Lucia: 就是先拿8个这个小碗
Lucia: Let's take out eight small bowls first.
Alice:白菜手撕的好吃
Alice: Cabbage tastes better when hand-torn.
Alice:谁懂
Alice: Who knows that?
Lucia: 啊太好了有白菜
Lucia: Ah, great, we have cabbage.
Lucia: 我还以为白菜咱昨天用完了呢
Lucia: I thought we finished it all yesterday.
Alice:没有我只用了叶没用包
Alice: No, I only used the leaves, not the head.
Alice:有点废水这样洗但是无所谓
Alice: Washing like this wastes some water, but it's fine.
Lucia: 我到楼下看看楼下的碗够不够
Lucia: I'll go downstairs and check if there are enough bowls.
Lucia: 要楼下碗够
Lucia: Need more bowls from downstairs.
Lucia: 把楼下碗拿上来算了
Lucia: Just bring the bowls up from downstairs.
Alice:什么白菜这么脏
Alice: Why is this cabbage so dirty?
Tasha: 走一下线
Tasha: Let's run the cable.
Shure: 回来了
Shure: I'm back.
Jake:三颗钱还是什么
Jake: Three coins or what?
Alice:怎么洗不掉呢奇怪
Alice: Why can't this be washed off? Weird.
Katrina: 非常非常丰富
Katrina: Very, very rich.
Jake:三三颗出伪金币吗还是
Jake: Three fake coins or what?
Katrina: 哈哈哈都有
Katrina: Hahaha, there's everything.
Jake:什么都有
Jake: Everything, huh?
Jake:很多是吧
Jake: There's a lot, right?
Jake:要火要火
Jake: It needs to be hot.
Shure: 没人吧
Shure: No one's here, right?
Katrina: 哇团建的感觉
Katrina: Wow, feels like a team-building event.
Jake:一会开吃了再结束吧
Jake: Let's start eating and then wrap up.
Jake:就是把这个都拆开
Jake: Just unpack everything.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 我们来来个同学帮我一下
Shure: Can someone help me out here?
Jake:来要干啥
Jake: What do you need?
Alice:这啥玩意怎么洗不掉呢
Alice: What is this thing? Why can't it be washed off?
Shure: 直接倒到那里面
Shure: Just pour it in there.
Shure: 省得我一点一点接了是吧
Shure: So I don't have to do it bit by bit, right?
Katrina: 诶从哪搞两股啊
Katrina: Hey, where to get two strands?
Jake:哦哦走赶走
Jake: Oh, oh, let's move.
Shure: 然后这个拿着吧
Shure: And then hold this.
Shure: 别别让这个粘着那什么
Shure: Don't let this stick to anything.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Alice:不知道为什么这洗不掉
Alice: I told you it can't be washed off.
Jake:你别碰他
Jake: Don't touch it.
Alice:这什么玩意
Alice: What is this thing?
Jake:就这样就行了
Jake: It's fine like this.
Lucia: 有就是有的菜叶子上它就
Lucia: Some leaves just have it.
Jake:就没必要了
Jake: It's not necessary.
Lucia: 就长这样还是怎么回事
Lucia: They just grow like this or something.
Lucia: 我们家洗菜也是
Lucia: At home, we wash veggies too.
Lucia: 就是有时候这个东西它是洗不掉的
Lucia: Sometimes you just can't wash it off.
Alice:摸摸
Alice: Feel it.
Jake:倒个数据呗
Jake: Pour the data.
Lucia: 应该它就长这样
Lucia: It should look like this.
Alice:好像长上去了一样
Alice: It seems like it has grown up.
Jake:数据倒了倒了
Jake: The data is down, it's down.
Lucia: 对它就长这样
Lucia: Yes, it looks like this.
Alice:好你给我做个见
Alice: Alright, give me a proof.
Alice:证啊
Alice: A proof.
Alice:放心吧我确实洗了
Alice: Don't worry, I did wash it.
Lucia: 好放心吧
Lucia: Okay, don't worry.
Lucia: 他就长这样
Lucia: He looks like this.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Katrina: 哇哦
Katrina: Wow.
Shure: 这放放顶上
Shure: Put it on top.
Shure: 不然话我一会钻不过去
Shure: Otherwise, I won't be able to get through.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 我对我自己几斤几两非常有点逼数
Shure: I know very well what I'm capable of.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Shure: 呦呦呦
Shure: Yo yo yo.
Lucia: 你小心小心
Lucia: Be careful, be careful.
Lucia: 主要是别碰到接口什么的地方
Lucia: Just don't touch the connectors or anything.
Katrina:  没事擦一下吧
Katrina: It's okay, just wipe it.
Lucia: 呃楼上是不是没有抹布好像哎有
Lucia: Uh, is there no cloth upstairs? Wait, there is.
Tasha: 这个水明显少了
Tasha: This water is clearly less.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 没事我们一会拿那个开水直接补吧
Shure: It's okay, we can just add some hot water later.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:用娃哈哈的水
Jake: Use Wahaha water.
Lucia: 呃
Lucia: Uh.
Jake:啊用娃哈哈的水
Jake: Ah, use Wahaha water.
Lucia: 啊娃哈哈的水就是说它的水很健康啊
Lucia: Ah, Wahaha water, meaning it's very healthy.
Lucia: OK实验室用水
Lucia: OK, lab water.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Hahaha, no, no.
Jake:我乱说的
Jake: I'm just kidding.
Katrina: 想喝个饮料
Katrina: I want to drink something.
Jake:本身我们还有一个环节
Jake: Actually, we have another part.
Jake:就是给你们五六种这种矿泉水
Jake: We give you five or six kinds of mineral water.
Jake:让你们去分
Jake: And you figure them out.
Shure: 啊可以啊
Shure: Ah, that's doable.
Lucia: 然后呢谁先把这些水喝完谁是赢家吗
Lucia: And then, whoever drinks all the water first wins, right?
Jake:谁能分辨得出来
Jake: Whoever can tell the difference.
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem.
Shure: 万事俱备
Shure: Everything's ready.
Shure: 只他娘的欠东风
Shure: Just need that final touch.
Shure: 东风是什么呢
Shure: What is that final touch?
Shure: 东风就是火锅底料
Shure: It's the hot pot base.
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why?
Tasha: 火锅底料呢
Tasha: The hot pot base?
Tasha: 那个那个所有的料的那个袋子
Tasha: The bag with all the ingredients.
Katrina: 在楼下
Katrina: It's downstairs.
Tasha: 哦对
Tasha: Oh right.
Tasha: 在楼下
Tasha: It's downstairs.
Tasha: 是不是还要拿一些
Tasha: Should we get some more?
Tasha: 8个碗 8个碟
Tasha: 8 bowls, 8 plates.
Tasha: 嗯碗有
Tasha: Hmm, we have bowls.
Tasha: 但盘子不够
Tasha: But not enough plates.
Tasha: 咱就用小碗吧嗯
Tasha: Let's just use small bowls then.
Lucia: 因为他这的盘子都是那种大一点的
Lucia: Because the plates here are all kinda big.
Lucia: 而且好像没有8个
Lucia: And I don't think we have 8.
Lucia: 至少楼上没有
Lucia: At least not upstairs.
Lucia: 不过小碗已经都拿出来了
Lucia: But I've already got the small bowls out.
Tasha: 就拿碗吧
Tasha: Let's just use bowls.
Lucia: 对然后那有3个是楼下洗过
Lucia: Yeah, and there are 3 more washed downstairs.
Lucia: 我直接拿上来了
Lucia: I just brought them up.
Tasha: 一二三四五五个
Tasha: One, two, three, four, five, five bowls.
Lucia: 然后对然后
Lucia: Right, and then...
Lucia: 呃池子里应该还有几个
Lucia: Um, there should be a few more in the sink.
Lucia: 反正我刚把底下都拿出来了
Lucia: Anyway, I brought everything up from downstairs.
Lucia: 我先去拿一下那个调料
Lucia: I'll go get the seasoning first.
Tasha: 帮我把菜端过去
Tasha: Help me carry the dishes over.
Tasha: 吃饭也要开棚
Tasha: Even for eating, we need to set up.
Jake:iPhone
Jake: iPhone.
Jake:今天比较富裕
Jake: We're quite well-off today.
Shure: 有有一个
Shure: Yeah, we have one.
Jake:今天是富裕上
Jake: Today we're well-off.
Shure: 要变成纯清汤
Shure: It's gonna turn into plain soup.
Shure: 这就一包啊
Shure: There's only one packet.
Katrina: 这就一包啊
Katrina: There's only one packet.
Tasha: 一包不能拆成两包用吗
Tasha: Can't we split one packet into two?
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Tasha: 他这个是写3-5人吃
Tasha: It says it's for 3-5 people.
Katrina: 他这个你撕一下
Katrina: Tear this one for him.
Shure: 其实也不是不行
Shure: Actually, it's not impossible.
Katrina: 对他应该是一锅的量
Katrina: Yeah, it's probably enough for one pot.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What should we do?
Katrina: 然后就分成两个半
Katrina: Then just split it into two halves.
Tasha: 我也撕开
Tasha: I'll tear it too.
Shure: 我们我们吃辣的水平是什么样的
Shure: What's our spice tolerance level?
Shure: 家人们
Shure: Guys?
Katrina: 我很能吃辣
Katrina: I can handle a lot of spice.
Shure: OK四个全
Shure: OK, all four.
Shure: 下一个里
Shure: In the next one.
Katrina: 哈哈哈总有刁民想害朕
Katrina: Hahaha, there's always someone trying to mess with me.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 辣辣不死你
Shure: We'll spice you up!
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 明天不用拍摄
Shure: No filming tomorrow.
Shure: 大家都在厕所
Shure: Everyone will be in the bathroom.
Tasha: 那那就各分一半吧
Tasha: Then let's just split it in half.
Shure: 哎呦呦
Shure: Oh dear.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Tasha: 各分一半了
Tasha: It's split in half now.
Shure: 行行行这就各分一半吧
Shure: Alright, alright, let's just split it in half.
Katrina: 强制下班喽case
Katrina: Forced to clock out, case closed.
Tasha: 那这个火锅底料反正是4块
Tasha: This hot pot base is in four pieces anyway.
Tasha: 不如一个里面下两块
Tasha: How about putting two pieces in each pot?
Shure: 就我一个人下两块
Shure: I'll put two pieces in my pot.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Sure.
Shure: 这哪到哪
Shure: How far can it go?
Shure: 撒撒嘴吧就是
Shure: Just to spice up our mouths.
Katrina: 刚从成都回来
Katrina: Just got back from Chengdu.
Tasha: 一个是两
Tasha: One pot needs two pieces.
Tasha: 一个锅是下两块
Tasha: One pot needs half a bag.
Tasha: 一个锅是下半袋
Lucia: 啊下半袋的意思是
Lucia: Ah, does half a bag mean...
Lucia: 是这个里面少下一块吗
Lucia: Does it mean putting one less piece in this?
Lucia: 啊OK OK那这个也是拆开放到这里面
Lucia: Ah, OK, OK, then this one is also split and put in here.
Lucia: 那我就拆了
Lucia: Then I'll split it.
Tasha: 不要让两种味道混合
Tasha: Don't let the two flavors mix.
Shure: don t you
Shure: Don't you...
Lucia: 怎么只有这一锅水最多
Lucia: Why is there only this much water in the pot?
Katrina: 哎呀
Katrina: Oh no
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 啊这怎么办
Tasha: Ah, what do we do
Shure: 什么一袋
Shure: What, just one bag?
Katrina: 怎么了
Katrina: What's wrong?
Tasha: 只有一袋
Tasha: There's only one bag
Shure: 什么一袋不行吧
Shure: What? One bag is not enough
Tasha: 我的建议是把这个袋子撕开
Tasha: My suggestion is to tear open this bag
Tasha: 然后倒一半
Tasha: And then pour out half
Shure: 这无需撕开
Shure: No need to tear it open
Shure: 说明他不应该撕开
Shure: It means you shouldn't tear it open
Tasha: 那怎么办
Tasha: Then what do we do
Shure: 随便
Shure: Whatever
Shure: 小公鸡点到谁我就选谁好
Shure: I'll choose whoever the little rooster points to, okay?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha: 那这个锅的菌汤该有多么的孤单呀
Tasha: Then the mushroom soup in this pot will be so lonely
Tasha: 啊煮一半把它捞出来放这个锅里
Tasha: Ah, cook half of it and then scoop it out and put it in this pot
Shure: 哈哈哈流动料包
Shure: Hahaha, a mobile material pack
Lucia: 失策早知道两个锅当时应该买两包
Lucia: Bad planning, we should have bought two packs for two pots
Shure: 哦你在切东西
Shure: Oh, you're cutting something
Shure: 厕所有人吗
Shure: Is someone in the bathroom?
Shure: anyone
Shure: Anyone?
Shure: come in
Shure: Come in
Shure: 我要进来喽
Shure: I'm coming in
Tasha: 妈呀
Tasha: Oh my gosh
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 好多预热啊哈哈哈
Lucia: So much preheating, hahaha
Jake:严谨
Jake: Precise
Shure: 嘿嘿嘿
Shure: Hehehe
Lucia: 3次握手才能确定
Lucia: You have to shake hands three times to confirm
Jake:有啊有啊
Jake: Yes, yes
Lucia: 正在进行握手
Lucia: Shaking hands in progress
Lucia: 我觉得我们家网经常握手它就握不
Lucia: I think our home internet shakes hands so often it doesn't work
Shure: 这只扔了
Shure: Just throw this one away
Lucia: 上了
Lucia: It connects
Lucia: 十五秒抓把鸭肠
Lucia: Fifteen seconds to grab some duck intestines
Shure: 我们那个河马的那些袋子拿一个
Shure: Take one of those bags from the river horse
Shure: 然后当一个垃圾袋吧
Shure: And use it as a trash bag
Shure: 哎你就在那弄
Shure: Hey, just do it there
Shure: 那你先弄着
Shure: You handle that first
Lucia: 盒马袋子还有吗
Lucia: Do we still have Hema bags?
Lucia: 我去看看
Lucia: I'll go check.
Shure: 有吧应该
Shure: We should, I think.
Lucia: 哎我把我手机又撂哪
Lucia: Oh, where did I put my phone?
Lucia: 哎算放那了
Lucia: Oh well, I'll just leave it there.
Shure: 我们
Shure: Let's...
Shure: 放点电影看吧
Shure: Watch a movie.
Shure: 大家想看什么类型的电影吗
Shure: What kind of movie does everyone want to watch?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 那我们就看
Shure: Then we'll watch...
Shure: 就看
Shure: We'll watch...
Shure: 一些下饭的
Shure: Something light-hearted.
Shure: 哎我的电脑在哪里
Shure: Oh, where's my laptop?
Shure: 我看见了
Shure: I see it.
Shure: 我刚刚拿上来
Shure: I just brought it up.
Shure: 看见我的电脑吗
Shure: Did you see my laptop?
Shure: 在这里吗
Shure: Is it here?
Lucia: behold
Lucia: Behold.
Shure: 好啊好啊
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 他拿了一个大袋子
Shure: He brought a big bag.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 哪边水不够我们再补一点
Shure: If the water is not enough, we can add more.
Shure: 没有案楼下是不是有案板
Shure: Isn't there a cutting board downstairs?
Lucia: 我觉得这这是不是俩都有点少看起来
Lucia: I think both of these look a bit small.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 是不是应该拿个小盘
Shure: Should we get a small plate?
Shure: 这样然后这个是辣锅烧是吧
Shure: And this is the spicy pot, right?
Shure: 天啊太气
Shure: Oh my, so annoying.
Shure: 把那个门关上吧你们
Shure: Close the door, you guys.
Lucia: 哦微
Lucia: Oh, Tasha.
Shure: 不然话会窜进去味的
Shure: Otherwise, the smell will get in.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Lucia: 微你的门或者我帮你关
Lucia: Tasha, your door or I can close it for you.
Lucia: 如果你不介意的话
Lucia: If you don't mind.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's fine.
Shure: 关好哦大家
Shure: Close it properly, everyone.
Lucia: 我看看我那边啊
Lucia: I'll check my side.
Lucia: 我把我那边也关上
Lucia: I'll close mine too.
Alice:你们介意我把这个魔芋直接拽成块吗
Alice: Do you guys mind if I just tear the konjac into pieces?
Shure: 不介意拽吧
Shure: No, go ahead.
Shure: 我不介意
Shure: I don't mind.
Shure: 有介意的吗
Shure: Does anyone mind?
Shure: 他们不敢介意了好拽吧
Shure: They don't dare to mind, how cool is that?
Alice:好，开始随便
Shure: 对我们觉得拽着香
Shure: Yeah, we think being cool is awesome.
Shure: 就像手撕白菜一样
Shure: Just like tearing cabbage with your hands.
Lucia: 哦原来魔芋块是长这样的
Lucia: Oh, so that's what konjac looks like.
Alice:今天放飞自我了，我所谓了
Lucia: 小心手要不要把那个盘
Lucia: Be careful with your hand, do you want that plate?
Lucia: 案板是在楼下是吗
Lucia: Is the cutting board downstairs?
Alice:不用了懒得拿了
Lucia: 我再去拿一下好了
Lucia: I'll go get it.
Alice:没事我已经切完了
Alice: It's okay, I've finished cutting.
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Ah, alright then.
Alice:哈哈好像阴暗扭曲的一个人
Alice: Haha, I seem like a dark and twisted person.
Alice:还有什么需要弄的
Alice: Is there anything else that needs to be done?
Tasha: 好像没有了
Tasha: It looks like there's nothing left.
Alice:坐你旁边吧有纸吗
Alice: Can I sit next to you? Do you have any tissues?
Alice:又再来一个吧谢谢
Alice: Let's have another one, thanks.
Alice:我感觉我快没有存存储
Alice: I feel like I'm almost out of "eating dumb rat."
Tasha: 嗯蘸料呢哦
Tasha: Hmm, where's the dipping sauce?
Tasha: 蘸料是拿来了吗
Tasha: Did you get the dipping sauce?
Alice:蘸料是不是还搁底下呢
Alice: Is the yam still down there?
Lucia: 蘸料刚才好像修硕已经开了
Lucia: Shure just opened the dipping sauce earlier.
Alice:是不是在底下呀
Alice: Is it down there?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Tasha: 醋碟油碟
Tasha: The vinegar dish, the oil dish.
Shure: 呃都我只把麻酱给卸了
Shure: Uh, I only got the sesame paste ready.
Alice:没有油条就麻酱
Alice: No fried dough sticks, just sesame paste.
Lucia: 蘸料你是不是打开了一个
Lucia: Did you open a dipping sauce?
Tasha: 买了油买了
Tasha: Bought the oil, bought it.
Alice:我没有醋吗买了
Alice: No vinegar? Did we buy it?
Shure: 其他的还还没弄
Shure: The rest isn't done yet.
Lucia: 呃有点买了一个小的
Lucia: Uh, we bought a small one.
Lucia: 我去把它拿上来
Lucia: I'll go get it.
Tasha: 嗯油碟醋碟
Shure: 什么鬼你来呀来呀你
Shure: What the heck, come on, come on.
Shure: 大家想看什么呢
Shure: What does everyone want to see?
Shure: 大家想看什么呀
Lucia: 那个麻将我不太清楚放哪了
Lucia: I'm not sure where the sesame paste is.
Lucia: 但是这两个可以拿上来
Lucia: But I can bring these two up.
Shure: 放在楼下的这个这个地方
Shure: It's downstairs, in that spot.
Lucia: 啊确定吗
Lucia: Ah, are you sure?
Lucia: 我感觉那一块只有一些烘焙原料
Lucia: I think there's only some baking ingredients there.
Shure: 不他那一大碗就是麻酱
Shure: No, that big bowl is sesame paste.
Lucia: 啊哈我再看一眼
Lucia: Uh-huh, let me take another look.
Shure: 对那个碗是我卸好的麻酱
Shure: Yeah, that bowl is the sesame paste I prepared.
Tasha: 啊就带这个带的吗
Tasha: Oh, did you bring it with you?
Tasha: 确实会有点
Tasha: It does have a bit of...
Alice:洗干净没啊
Alice:差不多了
Alice:身上会很多味
Alice: It has a strong smell.
Tasha: 嗯吃完火锅
Tasha: Yeah, after eating hotpot.
Alice:是这样的
Tasha: 还好昨天
Tasha: Fortunately, yesterday...
Tasha: 也穿的这身
Tasha: I wore the same outfit.
Alice:我要洗一下吧。
Tasha: 碗吗？
Alice:我说衣服
Lucia: 先放在这大家一会自己
Lucia: Let's put it here for now, everyone can...
Tasha: 啊人怎么又不见了的感觉
Tasha: Oh, where did everyone go again?
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Lucia: 呃有俩人在楼下
Lucia: Uh, two people are downstairs.
Alice:他们回来了吗
Alice: Are they back?
Lucia: 哎不对啊
Lucia: Wait, no...
Lucia: 应该有三个回
Lucia: There should be three back.
Lucia: 回来了应该回来了
Lucia: They should be back, right?
Lucia: 应该有三个人在楼下呀
Lucia: There should be three people downstairs.
Alice:这个火力好像比较足
Alice:这个水位稍微多一点
Tasha: 这边这个为什么都不冒气
Alice:嗯
Lucia: 他是不是要把火再开大一些
Lucia: Should he turn up the heat a bit?
Alice:火锅
Tasha: 这是不是已经最大了
Alice:是
Alice:加不了了
Alice:这个水比这个水多一点所以会慢一点
Alice: There's a bit more water in this one, so it takes longer.
Tasha: 可能这边受热不均匀
Tasha: Maybe it's heating unevenly.
Tasha: 你看它这个圆圈在这里
Tasha: Look, this circle is here.
Tasha: 它这个圆圈
Tasha: This circle...
Shure: 知道为什么吗因为
Shure: Do you know why? Because...
Tasha: 这样
Tasha: Like this.
Alice:因为爱情，不会轻易悲伤
Shure: 它的功率大一点
Shure: Its power is a bit higher.
Shure: 哈哈哈没有什么为什么
Shure: Haha, there's no real reason.
Shure: 哦好
Shure: Oh, okay.
Alice:这个水还少呢
Alice: There's still less water here.
Shure: 是因为那个
Shure: It's because...
Shure: 我后来不是把开水几乎都加在这边了
Shure: I added almost all the boiling water here.
Tasha: 哦这边加的是开水
Tasha: Oh, you added boiling water here.
Shure: 所以他开水加的多一点
Shure: So there's more boiling water here.
Alice:晚上就熏入味了
Alice: It'll soak in the flavor overnight.
Alice:晚上的
Alice:看还有多少存储
Shure: 有酒能不喝开玩笑
Shure: If there's alcohol, of course we'll drink it.
Lucia: 已经把朗姆酒打开了
Lucia: I've already opened the rum.
Alice:看来这马上要没了
Alice: Looks like it's about to run out.
Alice:没存储现在已经快3小时了
Alice: No storage for almost 3 hours now.
Shure: 橙汁补满螺丝棋子
Shure: Refill the orange juice with screws and chess pieces.
Alice:嗯只有20个G了
Alice: Hmm, only 20GB left.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What's this?
Tasha: 哦好吧
Tasha: Oh, alright.
Shure: 好喝的小甜水
Shure: Delicious sweet water.
Alice:果汁
Shure: 一些酒鬼
Shure: Some drunkards.
Shure: 我可以让火小一点了
Shure: I can turn down the heat a bit.
Alice:上面有水吗
Alice: Is there water on top?
Shure: 有啊没有
Shure: Yes, no.
Alice:没有，那我下去拿吧
Tasha: 喝可乐就行
Tasha: Just drink Coke.
Tasha: 中午的可乐
Tasha: The Coke from noon.
Tasha: 我觉得火锅应该喝可乐
Tasha: I think we should drink Coke with hotpot.
Shure: 可乐有
Shure: We have Coke.
Shure: 还有啤酒要吗
Shure: And beer, do you want some?
Tasha: 小孩来这桌哈哈
Tasha: Kids, come to this table, haha.
Alice:给她拿一个吧
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 还有soda water
Shure: There's also soda water.
Shure: 气泡水
Shure: Sparkling water.
Tasha: 椰子水有吗也有
Tasha: Do you have coconut water too?
Alice:上面有吗
Shure: 上面也有
Shure: It's also on top.
Alice:你要水不要
Alice: Do you want water?
Alice:我去拿一瓶
Alice: I'll go get a bottle.
Tasha: 要什么
Tasha: What do you want?
Alice:水
Alice:我去拿哦
Alice: I'll go get it.
Tasha: 你可以拿对
Tasha: You can get it, right?
Tasha: 然后对你不喝饮料吗
Tasha: And you don't drink beverages?
Alice:还有啥需要拿上来的
Alice: What else do we need to bring up?
Tasha: 筷子有了
Tasha: We have chopsticks.
Shure: 想起来啥拿啥
Shure: Grab anything you think of.
Alice:这个洗
Tasha: 是不是少啊
Tasha: Are we missing anything?
Shure: 楼下还有筷子
Shure: There are more chopsticks downstairs.
Tasha: 哦还有碗是不是够
Tasha: Oh, and bowls, are they enough?
Shure: 对碗
Shure: Yes, bowls.
Alice:碗够吗
Alice: Are there enough bowls?
Shure: 也
Shure: Also.
Tasha: 碗和筷子就行了吧
Tasha: Bowls and chopsticks should be enough, right?
Lucia: 八个碗吗
Lucia: Eight bowls, right?
Alice:那筷子呢
Shure: 筷子筷子都拿上来吧
Shure: Bring up all the chopsticks.
Lucia: 筷子
Lucia: Chopsticks.
Alice:都拿上来
Alice: Bring them all up.
Lucia: 现在有一二为
Lucia: Now there are one, two...
Shure: 反正是8个人
Shure: Anyway, there are 8 people.
Lucia: 什么是5根筷子
Lucia: What are 5 chopsticks?
Tasha: 他拿走了一根
Tasha: He took one.
Tasha: 那就是四双
Tasha: So that's four pairs.
Lucia: 哦你拿走了一根
Lucia: Oh, you took one.
Lucia: 我以为你拿走了一双呢
Lucia: I thought you took a pair.
Tasha: 四双筷子
Tasha: Four pairs of chopsticks.
Tasha: 还差四双
Tasha: Four pairs short.
Alice:那我先去拿把
Alice: Then I'll go get them.
Lucia: 我刚想说你倒的好像很多
Lucia: I was just about to say you poured a lot.
Lucia: 但我以为是你比较能喝
Lucia: But I thought you could drink a lot.
Alice:上去吃饭了
Alice: Let's go eat.
Alice:都拿了吧
Alice:拿一瓶水
Alice: Grab a bottle of water.
Alice:再涮一下
Alice:上去吃饭了
Alice: Let's go eat.
Jake:好好好说说什么
Jake: Okay, okay, what are we talking about?
Alice:需要拿这个吗
Alice: Do we need to bring this?
Jake:我艾特你们一下啊
Jake: I'll tag you guys.
Alice:好像不太需要
Jake:哎就你就你
Jake: Hey, just you, just you.
Jake:就记一下几点再几点再吃饭
Jake: Just note the times and eat.
Alice:没什么东西要拿
Jake:对就行了啊
Jake: Yeah, that's enough.
Alice:叫了嗯但是无动于衷
Alice: Called them, but they didn't respond.
Shure: 叫了吗OK
Shure: Called them? Okay.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 再无动于衷咱就开吃
Shure: If they don't respond, we'll start eating.
Shure: 不等他们
Shure: We won't wait for them.
Shure: 惯着他们
Shure: Spoiling them.
Shure: 一天天的
Shure: Every single day.
Alice:先没有筷子
Alice: But we don't have chopsticks.
Shure: 吃饭都不积极
Shure: Not even eager to eat.
Alice:你要尖筷子还是圆筷子
Alice: Do you want pointed or round chopsticks?
Tasha: 啊呃
Tasha: Uh...
Alice:只有一双圆筷子
Alice: There's only one pair of round chopsticks.
Tasha: 那就是好
Tasha: That's fine.
Tasha: 那我就要这双特殊的圆筷子
Tasha: Then I'll take the special round chopsticks.
Tasha: 不我还是要尖筷子吧
Tasha: No, I'll take the pointed ones.
Alice:那我也要尖筷子
Alice: I'll take the pointed ones too.
Alice:我要跟你一样
Alice: I want to be like you.
Alice:算了我用圆的吧
Alice: Never mind, I'll use the round one.
Alice:因为尖的我可能夹不住
Alice: Because I might not be able to hold the sharp one.
Lucia: 我也来一点
Lucia: I'll have a little too.
Shure: 高点
Shure: Higher.
Lucia: 哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, right.
Lucia: 不过我不敢倒你那么多
Lucia: But I don't dare to pour as much as you.
Shure: 你为什么不用杯子呀
Shure: Why don't you use a cup?
Lucia: 啊因为我懒
Lucia: Ah, because I'm lazy.
Tasha: 现在不给直播了
Tasha: We're not live streaming now.
Lucia: 就是我把这个喝完了
Lucia: So, once I finish this,
Lucia: 我就可以直接拿它来吃饭了哈哈
Lucia: I can use it directly to eat, haha.
Tasha: 我不知道结果
Tasha: I don't know the result.
Shure: 来点嘛雨轩
Shure: Come on, Yuxuan, have a bit.
Shure: 喝
Shure: Drink.
Shure: 就是橙汁加朗姆酒
Shure: It's just orange juice mixed with rum.
Shure: 好像橙汁不够
Shure: Seems like there's not enough orange juice.
Shure: 你其实对你们都喝不出来什么味
Shure: Honestly, you guys won't even taste anything.
Lucia: 啊太小看人了吧
Lucia: Ah, you're underestimating us too much.
Shure: 选个片吧选个片吧
Shure: Let's pick a movie, let's pick a movie.
Shure: 别让我的大脸在这地方待着
Shure: Don't let my big face stay here.
Shure: 太太可怕了
Shure: That's too scary.
Tasha: 是一个独立的国家
Tasha: It's an independent country.
Alice:哎怎么还是这个龙啊
Lucia: 哎把壁纸换了
Lucia: Hey, change the wallpaper.
Tasha: 还是这局
Tasha: Still this game.
Shure: 这是我iPad壁纸
Shure: This is my iPad wallpaper.
Jake:啊这个能播吗
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:这个能播吗
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
Tasha: 这为什么不能播
Tasha: Why can't it be broadcast?
Shure: 你还帮忙监督着是吗哈哈
Shure: Are you still supervising, haha?
Tasha: 哦刚刚那段话吗
Tasha: Oh, that sentence just now?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Shure: 我也很开心
Shure: I'm also very happy.
Shure: 因为我有酒喝
Shure: Because I have alcohol to drink.
Lucia: 没事就算橙汁用完了
Lucia: It's okay, even if we run out of orange juice,
Lucia: 咱还有可乐
Lucia: we still have cola.
Shure: 这个兑可乐好喝吗
Shure: Does this mix with coke taste good?
Lucia: 自由古巴
Lucia: Cuba Libre.
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What's up?
Lucia: 自由古巴的传统兑法吗
Lucia: Is it the traditional way of making Cuba Libre?
Tasha: 这是一道裂痕
Tasha: This is a crack.
Lucia: 这不是老母加可乐
Lucia: This isn't a Rum and Coke.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:你这
Alice: You...
Alice:你这屏幕裂了吗还是膜
Alice: Did your screen crack or is it just the protector?
Tasha: 不是膜
Tasha: It's not the protector.
Alice:感觉有个头发呢
Tasha: 什么时候开饭
Tasha: When are we eating?
Jake:可以开了是吧
Jake: Can we start now?
Shure: 可以开始了
Shure: We can start.
Shure: 其实摆起来吧咱们
Shure: Actually, let's set things up.
Alice:碗没拿过来
Alice: We didn't bring the bowls.
Jake:那就摆起来
Jake: Then let's set up.
Jake:摆起来开
Jake: Set it up and start.
Alice:你的醋
Shure: 然后把这个机器停了吧
Shure: And then let's stop the machine.
Shure: 别别弄坏了
Shure: Don't break it.
Jake:这个开完就结束录制
Jake: We'll finish recording after this.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Got it.
Jake:开把摆起来
Jake: Start and set up.
Shure: 到时候没喝完的都得带回去
Shure: Whatever we don't finish drinking, we take back.
Tasha: 哦然后又不不不录了就开始正正哦
Tasha: Oh, and then we won't record and just start...
Jake:然后就不录对对对
Jake: Then we won't record, right.
Alice:啊蚂蚁爬上来了
Alice: Ah, ants are climbing up.
Alice:把这个不要了
Jake:这怎么开
Jake: How do we open this?
Jake:这叫刀划吗
Jake: Is this called cutting with a knife?
Alice:刀在那呢
Jake:哎在哪
Jake: Hey, where is it?
Alice:那
Jake:有有刀是吗
Jake: Do we have a knife?
Alice:有
Shure: 我还没没确定坐那
Shure: I haven't decided where to sit yet.
Shure: 橙汁不够了
Shure: We're out of orange juice.
Shure: 可能有点浓
Shure: It might be a bit strong.
Shure: 啊可以往里兑氧和毒
Shure: We can mix in oxygen and poison.
Lucia: 这个也开了吧要不
Lucia: Should we open this too?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:8个人两个过合适吧
Jake: Two bottles for 8 people is fine, right?
Lucia: 特别合适
Lucia: Perfect.
Lucia: 这这好紧啊
Lucia: This is so tight.
Jake:看你直播
Jake: Watch your stream.
Lucia: 啊好
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 谢谢我看看有啥人能直接撕的
Lucia: Thanks, let me see if there's anything that can be torn directly.
Shure: 我们看点什么
Shure: What should we watch?
Lucia: 这是不能撕开啊
Lucia: This can't be torn open.
Shure: 我们看点啥
Shure: What should we watch?
Lucia: 这能撕开耶
Lucia: This can be torn open!
Tasha: 是你们3个人的绿豆糕
Tasha: It's mung bean cake for the three of you.
Lucia: 个人的绿豆糕啊
Lucia: Mung bean cake for each person?
Tasha: 因为你们3个刚刚不在
Tasha: Because the three of you were not here just now.
Tasha: 呃你猜
Tasha: Uh, guess what?
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 可以试哈哈
Lucia: You can try, haha.
Jake:这是一个好问题
Jake: That's a good question.
Jake:一款可以问PUA
Jake: You can ask a PUA.
Lucia: 虾滑就下的时候再撕吧
Lucia: Tear the shrimp paste when we put it in.
Lucia: 呃这这这咋放呀
Lucia: Uh, how do we place this?
Jake:这个也可以撕
Jake: This can also be torn.
Jake:这个怎么
Jake: How about this?
Jake:这是这是那个
Jake: This is, this is the...
Lucia: 这是那个豆皮啥的应该
Lucia: This should be the bean curd thing, right?
Shure: 腾讯会员
Shure: Tencent membership.
Jake:我来
Jake: I'll do it.
Lucia: 咱为啥买了两个毛肚妈
Lucia: Why did we buy two beef tripe, mom?
Shure: 经典搞笑是吧
Shure: Classic comedy, right?
Alice:这撕了吗
Alice: Has this been torn?
Shure: 吓得我特烦恼
Shure: It scared me a lot.
Lucia: 呀
Lucia: Ah!
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Lucia: 撕了撕了
Lucia: It's torn, it's torn.
Lucia: 但是它里面还有个袋子
Lucia: But there's another bag inside.
Jake:随便看看
Jake: Just take a look.
Jake:这段不录你爱怎么
Jake: This part isn't recorded, do as you like.
Lucia: 我知道外面这层撕了
Lucia: I know the outer layer is torn.
Jake:哎不对
Jake: Wait, no.
Lucia: 里面那可能是我也不知道它啥意思
Lucia: I'm not sure what the inner part means.
Jake:有一圈摄像头在录
Jake: There's a circle of cameras recording.
Lucia: 下的时候再撕还是什么吧
Lucia: Tear it when we put it in or something.
Shure: 就是要放能播的是吗
Shure: We need to show something that can be broadcast, right?
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's fine, it's fine.
Jake:go Pro
Jake: Go Pro.
Jake:放脸能播的
Jake: Show your face, it's good for broadcasting.
Jake:go Pro还在拍
Jake: The GoPro is still recording.
Lucia: 真真的吧
Lucia: Is it really?
Tasha: 素毛肚吧
Tasha: Is it tripe?
Jake:就是你你在塞博吃火锅
Jake: It's like you're having hotpot in Cyber.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This.
Alice:洗一下吗这个
Alice: Should we wash this?
Alice: 哎这个  汁
Alice: Oh, this one?
Alice:9个呢
Alice: There are 9 of them.
Shure: 不干不净
Shure: Dirty or clean.
Shure: 吃了没病
Shure: Eating it won't make you sick.
Lucia: 我哎
Lucia: Oh, I...
Lucia: 我以为他这种包装都是直接吃的嘞
Lucia: I thought this kind of packaging meant you could eat it directly.
Lucia: 不了解
Lucia: I don't know.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 给大家表演一个人类洗毛肚啊
Shure: Let me show everyone how to wash tripe.
Jake:可以记下来
Jake: You should write it down.
Lucia: 啊你真的系了
Lucia: Oh, you really did it.
Alice:咋了
Tasha: 把这个包
Tasha: Wrap this up.
Lucia: 记一些高光时刻是
Lucia: Capture some highlight moments.
Alice:这个没有吗
Alice: Doesn't this one have it?
Tasha: 所以我们决定两边一起共用
Tasha: So we decided to share both sides.
Alice:好
Shure: 经典不知道看什么时候
Shure: Classic, don't know when to watch.
Shure: 就看点夏洛特烦恼
Shure: Just watch "Goodbye Mr. Loser."
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:迭代一下
Jake: Iterate a bit.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:还没迭代
Jake: Haven't iterated yet.
Jake:迭代迭代
Jake: Iterate, iterate.
Jake:多换几个
Jake: Change a few more.
Jake:人气就一直很嗨
Jake: The popularity will stay high.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:开空调吗
Jake: Turn on the air conditioner?
Lucia: 我直接我建议我直接用碗喝水了
Lucia: I suggest I just use a bowl to drink water.
Alice:开吧
Lucia: 所以一会就用这个碗吃
Lucia: So I'll use this bowl to eat later.
Jake:遥控器在哪啊空调
Jake: Where's the remote for the air conditioner?
Lucia: 嗯好问题
Lucia: Hmm, good question.
Alice:是不在那个沙发上那个是吗
Alice: Is it not on that sofa?
Lucia: 白色
Lucia: White.
Shure: 黑色是电视
Shure: The black one is the TV.
Alice:是不是开空调的时候放下去了还是
Alice: Did it fall when we turned on the air conditioner?
Shure: 这也不是
Shure: Nope, not that either.
Shure: 这是那什么的
Shure: It's from that thing.
Jake:放下去了吗
Jake: Did it fall?
Shure: 这呢这呢
Shure: It's here, it's here.
Shure: 这呢我放这了
Shure: Here, I put it here.
Jake:瞅一瞅去找一找啊
Jake: Take a look, go find it.
Alice:是吗
Alice: Really?
Jake:这个像确实像
Jake: This looks like it, definitely looks like it.
Shure: 就这就是
Shure: This is it.
Lucia: what's this
Lucia: What's this?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 谁调到22度我妈妈在家不揍你
Shure: Who set it to 22 degrees? If my mom was home, she would be mad.
Shure: 26度调好了
Shure: Set it to 26 degrees, it's done.
Jake:保护地球
Jake: Save the planet.
Jake:人人有责哈哈哈
Jake: It's everyone's responsibility, hahaha.
Shure: 就是这你说录进去多不好啊
Shure: This is it, you know, it's bad to record this.
Shure: 我们还用空调
Shure: We're still using air conditioners.
Shure: 他真的一点听不到哎
Shure: He really can't hear anything at all.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈我们仿佛在看默剧一样
Shure: Hahaha, it's like we're watching a silent movie.
Alice:给
Jake:嚯这确实经典
Jake: Wow, this is classic.
Jake:来我们干个杯
Jake: Let's have a toast.
Jake:就
Jake: Just...
Katrina:  come杯
Katrina: Come, cheers.
Jake:有有杯子吗
Jake: Do we have cups?
Alice:多了嗷给
Alice: Plenty, oh yeah.
Jake:好好杯子
Jake: Great, great, cups.
Shure: 应该喝不出来什么
Shure: Shouldn't taste like much.
Jake:我要把我爸把我茅台打上来
Jake: I'm bringing up my dad's Maotai.
Shure: 吧
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 那边一个这边一个
Shure: One over there, one over here.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Shure: 你往你往这边
Shure: You move this way.
Shure: 我们挤一挤
Shure: Let's squeeze in.
Tasha: 哈你跟老板坐这儿呗
Tasha: Ha, why don't you sit with the boss here?
Shure: 中间串一个
Shure: Let's fit one more in the middle.
Tasha: 他不用看电视
Tasha: He doesn't need to watch TV.
Tasha: 他要观察志愿者
Tasha: He needs to observe the volunteers.
Shure: 夏洛特烦恼哈哈
Shure: Charlotte Troubles, haha.
Tasha: 还演过
Tasha: He acted in it too.
Shure: 你演的是圆滑
Shure: You played the smooth-talker.
Alice:这个车标
Alice: This car logo.
Lucia: 玛莎拉蒂
Lucia: Maserati.
Alice:他演了这个车标
Alice: He acted as this car logo.
Lucia: 哦哈哈
Lucia: Oh, haha.
Jake:干杯吧
Jake: Cheers!
Shure: 干杯
Shure: Cheers!
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers!
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 啊那还行
Lucia: Ah, that's not bad.
Lucia: 那我拿这玩意也不是那么突兀
Lucia: So, holding this thing isn't so awkward after all.
Jake:哈哈哈确实
Jake: Haha, indeed.
Lucia: 哈哈哈谢谢你哈哈
Lucia: Haha, thank you, haha.
Jake:来干杯
Jake: Come on, cheers.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's do it.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: eagle life票房大卖哈哈哈
Shure: Eagle Life box office hit, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈大卖卖
Jake: Haha, big hit, hit.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:点击百亿开源
Jake: A hundred billion clicks, open source.
Shure: 希望点击百亿啊
Shure: Hope for a hundred billion clicks.
Tasha: 这不是开源开源产品吗
Tasha: Isn't this an open-source product?
Jake:卖卖卖
Jake: Sell, sell, sell.
Jake:对上万star
Jake: Yes, ten thousand stars.
Jake:这个可以
Jake: This is possible.
Jake:专业这个专业
Jake: Professional, this is professional.
Shure: OK那我们stop recording
Shure: OK, then we stop recording.
Alice:老板有筷子吗
Alice: Boss, do you have chopsticks?
Jake:这是吗不是
Jake: Is this it? No.
Alice:你的筷子呢
Alice: Where are your chopsticks?
Jake:十恶不露
Jake: Don't show your ten evils.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:对你不用场景
Jake: No, you don't need the scenario.
Shure: 有勺子吗
Shure: Do we have a spoon?
Shure: 对咱没有勺子
Shure: Right, we don't have a spoon.
Shure: 怎么把这个麻将舀出来呢
Shure: How are we going to scoop out this mahjong?
Jake:咱有有点勺子
Jake: We do have some spoons.
Jake:有塑料勺子
Jake: There are plastic spoons.
Jake:会画吗哈哈哈哈
Jake: Can you draw? Hahaha.
Shure: 不会不会
Shure: No, no, I can't.
Shure: 你这
Shure: You're...
Jake:谢谢这是啥呀
Jake: Thanks, what is this?
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh, wow.
Jake:自带美
Jake: Naturally beautiful.
Jake:嗯没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:对对对谢
Jake: Yeah, yeah, thanks.